Let's face it--
life is uncertain.
But one thing is certain--
we need a way to make
predictions and make decisions
under uncertainty.
Probabilistic models can
help you to answer
questions such as--
What are the odds that there
will be a long line at the
supermarket checkout counter?
How likely is it that my
GPS device is off by
more than 10 meters?
What are the odds that I will
have a car accident next year?
How likely is it that the air
traffic control radar will
miss the approaching plane?
Should I invest in the stock
market now, or wait?
Can I use a probabilistic model
of social networking
data to create a marketing
campaign?
How do we use a statistical
model to decide if a medical
treatment is effective?
How do I model the huge amounts
of data that are now
becoming available in so
many different fields--
Big Data, as they call it--
and extract useful
information?
I am John Tsitsiklis--
And I'm Patrick Jaillet.
Our mission in this class is to
give you the tools to model
and analyze uncertain
situations, no matter what
your discipline.
To do that, we will use the
language and precision of
mathematics.
But we will also build
your intuition.
This is an ambitious class.
The online version is at the
same level as the one offered
to MIT students.
It covers a lot of material.
Beyond the basics, you will
learn about random processes
and about extracting information
from data.
In the end, you will be able to
make much better sense of
the uncertainty around you.
The rewards are certain
to come.
Let's face it--
life is uncertain.